if there is some good news that has come
over the last week it is that it appears
the trans-pacific partnership is dead
New York Democratic Senator Chuck
Schumer is potentially going to be the
Senate's top Democrat he told labor
labor leaders late last week that the
trans-pacific partnership is dead and is
not going to be made law by Congress
Schumer relayed statements that
Republican congressional leaders had
made to him according to an aide that
confirmed the remarks we've heard from
Hillary Clinton that she was against the
trans-pacific partnership most recently
I guess although she had made a number
of protein PP comments prior to becoming
the candidate the Democratic nominee for
president we heard from uh Donald Trump
that he is against the trans-pacific
partnership we also read some rumors
late last week that President Obama was
going to try to push TPP through in the
last month's of his present press
president presidency there is every
indication that that is not going to
happen and that's really really good
news we heard also from Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell who said that
there is no chance that the deal would
pass during President Obama's final
months in office industry groups are not
happy about this this includes farming
lobbies this includes retailers like
Walmart and jcpenney generally speaking
if Walmart isn't happy about something
we may be on the right track pad well I
think the whole idea was to keep TPP
under the radar so the Congress and
President could pass and approve it yeah
but because of the campaign it just got
way too much attention and even Hillary
Clinton I guess for political expediency
he hosed it I guess we believe that she
was against it or at least that's the
position she ran with and Donald Trump
has actually interestingly made
Republican voters very anti free trade
without having a clue what it's actually
about it's it's sort of an uninformed
policy for many Trump supporters but in
some ways it's a pilot policy that may
allow some overlap between the ideas of
Donald Trump and the ideas that we heard
from Bernie Sanders as I've talked about
before the real issue though is that the
term free trade and trade agreement is
very often a misleading propaganda term
when we talk about NAFTA when we talk
about TPP
these are corporate trade entitlements
the TPP borders on what we might call
corporate fascism free trade is a term
that is used because it sounds a lot
better to some people Pat but when we
actually look at what TPP is and when we
talk about a trade agreement TPP gives
tons of power to big corporations I feel
like lots of the people that are
opposing TPP because Trump says it's bad
don't even really understand what it's
about and you look at that the coalition
between Bernie supporters and Trump
supporters yeah as a wide range of
people opposed to this I think it's
going to be an important skill to have
as progressives for the next four years
to recognize silver linings when they
exist and the non passage of TPP if
indeed is what is going to happen that's
a really really good thing now is there
some trumpeters who again they're
completely clueless about the
implications of TPP they know that Trump
said it's bad so it's bad they are
already crediting the president-elect
status of Donald Trump as the reason why
it's not going to happen I don't know if
you've been paying attention for the
last six months or so but if it's been
it as something that many in Congress
have been against 02 to put this on the
list of trumps accomplishment days after
he's elected I think that's a little
far-fetched but hey politics make
strange bedfellows and we will see what
else turns up from Donald Trump be
President of the United States that
maybe progressives can look at and say
hey you know what this guy is a
cartoonish buffoon but here's something
that's good that at least happened under
his watch if not at his direction send
me your thoughts about the send me your
thoughts about the future of TPP i'm on
twitter at d pakman we will take a break
what a show we have for you today warby
parker is offering a free five day home
try-on to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I
more than 30 seconds to actually figure
out whether I like the glasses so with
the Warby Parker home try-on I was able
to pick five pairs that i liked put them
on in the comfort of my own home pick
the one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like three hundred
dollars for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need you can try
five pairs and see what you like check
out the at-home trial and support our
show by going to Warby Parker dot-com /
tdps it costs nothing